[Music]
joining me today is a senior fellow and
distinguished chair in diplomacy and
security at the RAND Corporation
previously he has held State Department
and White House posts including
Assistant Secretary of State for Europe
special assistant to the president for
the Western Hemisphere special advisor
to the president secretary of state for
the Balkans and ambassador to the
European community he has served under
George W Bush and Bill Clinton and in
2013 he returned to the State Department
to become the Obama administration
Special Representative for Afghanistan
and Pakistan ambassador James Dobbins
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
that was the longest intro I've ever
read yeah well I never could hold a job
yeah we actually cut a little bit out of
that just so that for brevity's sake I
could have done an hour just reading
your resume that is that is quite a
resume how does someone build a resume
like that how did you even get into this
world that would lead to all of those
jobs that we're gonna spend the next
hour talking about well I mean partly
joining the American Foreign Service
gets you a pretty broad spectrum I mean
you're supposed to change jobs every two
or three years change countries change
languages I think my job my pattern is
perhaps been a little more eclectic than
others it's partly luck just being in
the right place at the right time I my
first assignment was to Paris and LBJ
launched the Vietnam peace talks and I
was attached to it just because I was
there and spent a year with Averill
Harriman and Cyrus Stan's trying to
negotiate peace in Vietnam that was just
your serendipity yeah when you look back
at all the years that you've been
involved in this does it seem like
things have changed a lot or in a weird
way have things not changed so much um I
think I think things have changed a lot
in the last year the last years
specifically yeah
after a you know I think 50 years of of
continuity I mean I think the Cold War
was all of a piece things alternated a
fairly narrow band there was a debate
between doves and hawks but it wasn't a
polarized it wasn't a politically
polarized debate the Hawks weren't all
Republicans and the does were all
Democrats quite the contrary you had
many Hawks in the Democratic Party and
doves and the Republicans and so the
debate was of a different character so I
and although the world seems more
complex there are 170 countries there
when I started there were only 40 or so
if you look back at the kinds of
problems that Harry Truman faced at the
end of the Second World War
kind of say you know things are not
really worse today I mean that there was
you know there was famine there was a
huge population transfers there were
countries developing nuclear weapons
that were dedicated enemies of the
United States and so in that sense we
should we should be a little modest in
expecting that our world is so much more
complicated and so much more demanding
than then than that of those who came
before us yeah I like the way you frame
that too because it seems to me that and
partly because of social media and the
way we get information and watching
things on YouTube and podcasts the way
people get this that it seems like all
the time people think things are worse
than ever before but when you frame it
within well look what happened after
World War two countries being carved up
weapons population transfers all of
these things it does give a little
context and I think can help calm people
down do people seem from from where you
sit do people seem a little the average
person seemed a little crazier about
this I think that I mean I think that it
is an information overload
it's it's you know you're you're
drinking from a firehose and and there's
there's no mediation you know
traditionally
the broadcast media that newspapers
decided what was important they ranked
it you know front page middle page top
of the fold bottom of the fold first
stop is the anchor going out to this
crisis or is it just a correspondent so
you could put everything in a context of
a hierarchy now that's no longer the
case now your attention is constantly
being demanded and assaulted by
assertions that this is important that's
important and and it's left to the
individual to sort these things out yeah
do you miss the old days of that as
someone that's seeing the change now
yeah I think I think it puts a pressure
I don't think that actual events actual
pressures on the United States are
greater than they have been in the past
but I think the need to respond in real
time immediately to every single event I
mean somebody dies here you got to do it
it perpetuates um you know there's a
shooting here you've got to come out
with a statement means that a lot of
time is is wasted may not be quite the
right word but a lot of time is spent
dealing with ephemera mm-hmm so as
someone that is has spent their whole
life basically in the thick of foreign
policy does it depress you to think
about how little most Americans know
about foreign policy it's one of those
things for example we're going to talk
about a whole bunch of countries of
course the next hour and it's like when
I see people talking about Iran or I see
people talking about North Korea and I
think man most of these people really
have have no concept of what the real
discussions are what the real Iran deal
says or the mechanisms by which we can
verify it or what really is happening
behind the scenes in North Korea or any
of that stuff but everyone's talking
about all these things all the time do
you think people are informed should
they be more informed as a certain
amount of being uninformed help a
populous what do you think I think the
difference is that people in the old
days people were uninformed and they
knew they were under okay today they're
uninformed and they're not this is an
incredible distinction you're making out
there and so and so they have strong
opinions based on on on on
on data which may or may not be of any
you know reliability and and and they're
not and they're no there's no longer a
deference to expertise this is true not
just this is true not just diplomacy I
mean they're people who won't get
vaccinated despite the fact that all the
doctors tell them they should vaccinate
their children sure so it's a there's
there's a there's there's there's simply
less deference to to expertise is less
deference to science there's less
deference to to government and that's
overtime that's quite dangerous yeah so
what are some of the just broad things
that people should know about foreign
policy I know I'm giving you a sort of
wide one there but just the general like
I just feel like people just don't
understand anything for example right
now I want to talk a little bit about
North Korea but as an example you know
Trump is is using a lot of over-the-top
language related to North Korea and then
the North Koreans are using a lot of
over-the-top language related to us not
to me that has a lot to do with
deterrence and and with Trump especially
it's an element of what's this guy
actually thinking which actually could
be potentially good to stop enemies that
sort of thing but what are just some of
the basic things people should know
about foreign policy in general well I
mean foreign policy is mostly about on
the one hand it's mostly about relations
between states now there are non states
like the Islam you know like terrorist
movements in others but mostly you're
dealing with States governments
bureaucracies institutions and so
diplomacy is about knowing how states
and institutions work and how they can
be influenced what whereas the levers
that you can push that'll get a
government to do what you want to do or
not do what you don't want them to do
but secondarily you know institutions
are made up of people and in the end
it's all about how to influence
individual people which you know
normally involves building a degree of
trust at least operational trust within
a narrow spectrum of if I do this when
you do that and can
I count on you to actually follow
through so in the end it comes down to
after you get through the understanding
the mecca of international relations of
how institutions work and how to
influence them it comes down to the
interpersonal relations and how to
actually talk to individuals directly or
indirectly and how to get people to
change their mind to enter into into
into meaningful bargains and to keep
their promises how much does that change
from administration to administration as
someone that worked under several
presidents Clinton George W Bush and and
Obama how much does that does that all
come from the top and and you know they
sort of lay out what their vision is and
then the individuals at all the
departments sort of just take that and
run with it or are there things from
administration to administration that
sort of just remain basic policy well I
think again I think minuite particularly
during the Cold War from from one
ministration uh there were there are
differences of emphasis the rhetoric
changed politicians tended to to give
the impression that they there were more
changes than in fact took place right so
I guess that in a narrow spectrum of
what was possible in principle and so
that's one thing that that has eroded
there now are wider variations I think
but again I would say I mean the current
situation really is abnormal it's
there's there's no real comparison you
can compare you can compare Carter to
Reagan or Clinton the bush you know but
but those were still within a fairly
narrow spectrum of difference mm-hmm so
we're in a we're in an unparalleled era
of discontinuity in that regard now in
terms of administration's new new
administration's with inexperienced
presidents presidents who've not dealt
with national security before and that's
true of a lot of presidents sure
I mean Reagan Carter George W Bush
Clinton Kennedy these people had no
national security experience when they
entered office it was a rarity George HW
Bush you know had a lot but he was
unusual
they make early in big mistakes and then
get better over time if they have a
second term they're usually more
successful in this second term than the
first term the if you look at you know
Kennedy's Bay of Pigs invasion of Cuba
that went bad the first few weeks in
office LBJ's decision to reinforce and
greatly expand the u.s. commitment in
Vietnam early on in his his tenure
Clinton's debacle in Somalia which again
occurred in the first few weeks in his
office and of course the worst of all
george w bush's decision to invade Iraq
in the first year and a half in office
so costly mistakes improved performance
later on you can see the second terms of
presidents tend to be the ones that
leave the most meaningful legacies
behind and and again I think we're in a
we're in a unusual period I mean so far
Trump hasn't made the kind of costly
mistake that I've suggested others have
made others who were better prepared for
the job than he was so so far we've been
lucky in that regard will the luck hold
will he continue on balance to take the
advice of people like Madison and
Tillerson and McMasters who do have
experience and who and and who do be who
are playing a restraining role to some
degree I just don't know yeah but so
basically you like the the team that
he's assembled I sense from the way you
said that that you think that basically
this is a trustworthy group even if you
have your reservations about
his decision-making or his outlook I
think the national security team are
mostly mainstream representatives of the
national security establishment I think
many of them you know could have easily
been is easily appointed by Hillary
Clinton
I'm sure Hillary Clinton would have been
perfectly satisfied with mattis as a you
know or or McMaster as as senior people
in her administration
I think Tillerson is is a bit of an
enigma because his his policy instinct
seemed to be sound he seems to have
formed a team with mattis and McMaster
to kind of create you know channels to
keep the president from going off the
rails but his handling of the State
Department is almost inexplicable I mean
he's right that it that it was top-heavy
uh that it needed to be streamlined that
the number of bureaus and special envoys
that senior people needed to be cut back
first time I went to John Kerry staff
meeting I was surprised 100 people
showed up that morning staff me right it
was ludicrous right and half of them
were probably just assistants well
you're not most of them thought they
worked for the Secretary of State you
know directly yeah it had just gotten
out of control but the idea that you can
have you you can launch a study and not
to and not appoint anybody for a year
while you while you think about this
that's that's that's the world's just
moving too quickly yeah so do you think
that that Tillerson might actually be
good at getting rid of some of that
waste
I think he's already started yeah I have
to agree but but but I mean he's also
he's stopped hiring so you don't you
know I mean the Foreign Service is like
the military it's a Career Service you
come in at the bottom you gradually rise
to the top so you've got to keep
replenishing your seed corn mm-hmm you
need those guys who just came out of out
of grad school and who are who are going
to rise over 30 or 40 years to positions
of seniority and if you have a four-year
hiatus and hiring
you're gonna have serious problems later
on yeah so it's interesting what you
mentioned where you laid out a few of
the the mistakes or the probably
well-intentioned wrong events that
presidents got themselves into at the
beginning of their administrations and
yet you're acknowledging I mean we're
basically a year into Trump or almost a
year at this point and he hasn't gotten
into one of those so when he when he's
doing all of this the high level
rhetoric and saying you know we're gonna
wipe North Korea offer it's gonna be the
hell fire of whatever whatever it is he
says now I'm from what I understand you
don't really trust him in and of himself
but what do you make of just the the
deterrence factor of that because I'll
see a lot of people responding and
saying you see he's trying to start
World War three and again while I have
no idea what's going on in his mind I
hear some of those statements and I
think maybe he's really playing some
high-level game of we have no idea what
this is guy what this guy is going to do
and that actually is what deterrence is
all about am i giving him too much
credit there do you think well first of
all I don't think deterrence is about
not knowing what your adversary is going
to do it's quite the contrary it's
knowing where the red lines are and
letter step across them the consequences
are gonna be horrific right but is there
some level of deterrence if you just
don't know what that person is going to
do so if Trump says all of these things
we're gonna create Hellfire on earth or
whatever it is that is a level of
deterrence right it may be not in the
traditional sense I understand what
you're saying I think I mean it it
creates it creates a large zone in which
the other party doesn't know where where
the real red lines are how far they can
actually go so it it can have it can
have exactly the opposite consequences
of what you mm-hmm of what you intend it
can lead them to believe that steps that
they take are not going to lead to an
escalation that do I
so I mean deterrence is about create it
you know deterrence as a as a as a
strategy for dealing with the mutual
assured destruction
but the fact that if you get into an
actual conflict with a nuclear power
it's over you know
now North Korea isn't yet a nuclear
power of the of the type that can
destroy the United States but it's you
know certainly China Russia are
countries where if you escalate to a
nuclear war it will be the end of the
United States as a society and the end
of Russia and possibly the end of
mankind depending on on how you know how
how far this goes so so that's a
powerful deterrent and you need you need
to establish some sense of you know
what's what are the rules of the game
yes you can do this and then we'll do
that and we'll play tit for tat and if
you support them will support their
enemies and we'll get into a proxy
conflict but you know if you on the
other hand if you cross this line you
know that then you're going to be in a
direct confrontation which leads to do
catastrophe
and so this this kind of loose talk and
and the uncertainties it creates I think
is the opposite of a strategy of
deterrence now it may be a bargaining
tactic mm-hmm but but you know the
problem with that is that Trump is and
has said that it you know that he's used
to deals that you can walk away from
that that that you know you make an
offer if it's if you don't get the right
you you you you Bluff you push and then
if you don't get the right response you
just walk away
mm-hmm you know he's not in games you
can walk away from right these are games
that are going to continue into the
future indefinitely you're gonna be
dealing with rogue regimes and and
dangerous enemies in perpetuity and so
these are not these are not games where
you can play for a while and decide okay
the bluff didn't work and I'll go on to
the next deal with somebody else yeah I
think the distinction about rational
actors is important so perhaps we're
dealing with an irrational actor as our
president and certainly the North
Koreans have what seems to be an
irrational actor as opposed to the
Soviet Union and the United States and
during the Cold War we had basically
rational actors that that weren't gonna
have their own countries blown apart
just because something moved along in a
way that they didn't like yeah I mean I
I think that's I I think that's right I
think by and large both sides avoided
the kind of rhetoric which could lead to
misunderstanding miscalculation now
there were a few points particularly
during the first term of Ronald Reagan
where they asked elect or whether the
rhetoric had become quite heated evil
empire sort of rhetoric where the Soviet
Union we now know from Soviet records
was on a hair-trigger there was one
incident in which a Soviet Colonel saw
missile trails heading toward Moscow and
decided that it was an electronic ghost
and didn't and didn't launch the Rockets
which which his instructions had him
doing there was another point at which
after a lot of rhetoric we conducted a
nuclear exercise in which we exercised
the conducting a nuclear strike and the
Soviet Union thought that was a real
preparation for a nuclear strike and
again came quite close to perceiving
this as a as a pre-emptive American
strike and again we now know this from
from the records at the time yeah so so
we were closer a couple of times to the
kind of misunderstanding that could have
been casted catastrophic than we sensed
at the time but you're right that that
both sides understood the consequences
of a miscalculation and were very
careful to avoid it yeah and and and
both sides were in communications
established I mean you know Trump saying
don't talk to you know nobody to talk to
a little Rocket Man you know we we put
hot lines in between Moscow and
Washington mm-hmm precisely so that we
would always have a reliable form of
communication even in the worst of
circumstances yeah when you see him
tweet things like that like little
rocket man and all that stuff do you
think there's any chance that that is
that type of decision to tweet something
like that is getting to Tillerson before
he says it so you know like he'll is he
saying to Tillerson I'm gonna tweet
something kind of crazy but you're still
gonna handle everything or you just or
you think there's just an absolute
disconnect there I mean I mean I think
I mean I don't think anybody sees the
president sweets before he makes them I
mean you know he makes them at 6:00 in
the morning when no one else has come to
work right and he makes them based on
whatever he's seen in Fox News or some
other media source I think what happened
on the the Tillerson week was that
Tillerson went further than then the
White House including not just Trump
probably not just Trump but the White
House the whole when in acknowledging
that we had put out feelers to the north
areas and the White House didn't want
that known because they felt that weaken
their position you know that that it
looked like we were caving that way that
we were you know that we were the demand
or in this negotiation so I think the
and the president stomped on it you can
say that it was tiller son's fault
potentially because he hadn't cleared
what he said with the White House and
more if he did they didn't clear it with
the president so I think the president
was the one who was taken taken unawares
my killers and then of course teller son
was taken unawares by what the president
did yeah
so as somebody being I'm almost positive
they didn't orchestrate this right right
and I don't think he's orchestrating a
per se but it would almost be like there
would be this unsaid pact where he's
going I'm gonna tweet crazy stuff and
you're just gonna sort of clean up the
mess but again we're not my babies
implicit understanding yeah yes
but we just unfortunately we just don't
I don't know if anyone knows what the
answer is no I mean I I mean I think I
mean I think it's clear that Trump
wanted steady experienced people in the
National Security arena it didn't hire
ideologues as a rule didn't hire people
with strong
[Music]
contrast contrary or opinions in that
quickly moved Bannon out of the National
Security Council because he wanted that
source of stability probably because he
understands that there are consequences
for going too far but clearly that
that's only sort of one poll if you will
of his approach and the other poll is
this more instinctual it not to say
impulsive behavior based on a lifetime
of experience in a different kind of
negotiating environment yeah it's
interesting to me how much of this
really is based on trust I mean you have
to trust the people that you're working
with in the State Department but you
have to trust the actors that you're
talking to on the other side to act
rationally so I'm curious when sometimes
when our presidents have said things so
Trump now says things that it's a little
unclear whether they're true or not or
whether they're Bluffs or not or
whatever it is but something like the
Obama red line in Syria that you know he
said to the Assad regime if you were
going to if you use chemical weapons
this is the redline we're gonna do
saying and then we didn't I was I was
doing on-air stuff at the time and I
remember I did not want to go in I
thought we can leave this to Turkey or
Saudi Arabia or create some humanitarian
corridors or something so I did not want
it but to me once you set the red line
then you have to actually do something
do you think that's a fair assessment to
start yeah I mean I think there's an
issue of credibility and again I think
there's an issue of predictability if
you simply set red lines and then don't
follow them you've you you've undermined
the credibility of any future red lines
that you may set and and clearly Obama's
credibility you know had diminished as a
result of this now I I think it's a
little unfair that he didn't you know I
mean he you know the the he said you
know if you use chemical weapons will
respond then the Russians said well how
about if we get them to dismantle all
their chemical weapons and Obama grabbed
that as
as a need way out and and I think if
that was an isolated case if that that
that you could argue that that was a an
appropriate response and a nice outcome
you know they used chemical weapons once
you were gonna bomb them so they didn't
do it again Melissa was even better
they're not only weren't gonna do it
again they weren't even gonna be able to
do it again right so they were gonna get
rid of them all so assuming we trusted
that whole process well I mean I think
we it wasn't so much a question across
they got rid of huge amounts of chemical
weapons now the fact that they may have
retained a little bit it's fine but the
fact is I mean we know that tons and
tons of chemical weapons were in fact
handed over and destroyed mostly by us
mm-hmm so so I think in an isolated case
that that was but but I mean but I
personally I think we should have
intervened more forcefully in Syria
before the opposition had become
radicalized while they were winning and
the intrusion was losing at a point
where the regime was sovereign only in
the air on the ground they were losing
it's only in the air that they were
unchallenged we could have destroyed the
Syrian Air Force overnight without
losing a man or a plane in all
likelihood they would have lost the one
area where they was superior and they
would have easily been forced to some
kind of compromise or or have lost the
war and my judgment by that simple act
back in 2012 say but by the time you had
the red line and and that debate that
the opposition had become so radicalized
that they were actually worse than Assad
and so you really didn't want them to
win there were elements of them you'd
like to win but you couldn't separate
the bad from the good in the opposition
and the ongoing war was just a
catastrophe for the region and it
destabilized the politics in Europe and
even to a limited degree destabilize the
politics in the United States yeah it's
incredible how that one conflict within
Syria I mean it's led to the immigration
crisis across Europe it had definitely
something to do with some of the
sentiment that led to the rise of of
Trump here so what is the United suppose
the United States supposed to do or
what do you think the right thing for
the United States do is in a situation
like that where now we in effect have
two bad actors you know that there's no
good side here that at least that I know
of and yet there's I think it's over
300,000 people have been killed in the
last five or seven years I mean it's a
humanitarian crisis of epic proportions
what actually is the right thing to do
if we don't have an actor to play with
right I mean I it's obviously
situational in develop I think in 2012
we should have intervened on the part of
an opposition force which was legitimate
which was democratic which was moderate
and which was winning yeah I think today
the situation is very different I think
today the quicker the war is over the
better for us we don't like the fact
that Iran and Russia have influenced the
best way of diminishing their influences
diminish the need for Assad to depend on
them so getting the war over allowing
Assad to prevail is probably the fastest
way it doesn't eliminate Russian and
Syrian influence but it'll certainly
diminish it as he'll become less
dependent mm-hmm I think that we're
moving toward at least an interim
equilibrium in which you have a you a
u.s. protected zone in the east of the
country where the Kurds are operating
you have a Turkish protected zone in the
north of the country which is separating
the two Kurdish enclaves you have a
protected zone in the south of the
country needs the Israeli border which
the Russians the u.s. the Jordanians and
the Israelis have worked out which again
creates a though nor tranquility if you
will and then Assad basically
consolidates his hold over the rest and
and then the question is what what's the
next step that this will be an interim
lova lova lence situation some some
people are already going back the
outflow the inflows into Syria are now
slightly more really outflows but so so
people who actually left the country
because of the war are actually starting
to come back
some are really
limited numbers I mean you know there's
like I don't know the exact number
because I like millions and abroad and
tens of thousands are coming back so I
mean leave it even that's something else
so I mean I think you know the the main
instrument we will have to influence the
course of Syria is whether we provide or
withhold we've I mean the international
community Europe the United States the
Gulf states Saudi Arabia the World Bank
the IMF do we provide or withhold
reconstruction assistance and what can
we get for it yeah so I think you know
consolidating an interim ceasefire in
the country along the current battle
lines probably maintaining a small US
presence in that protected zone of the
Kurds and east for a while until the
Kurds and the regime come to some
understanding about limited autonomy for
their region and beginning
reconstruction tied to genuine elections
not at national level you're not going
to get rid of Assad but local elections
provide say we will provide assistance
to any city or town that holds a local
election and has a democratically
elected local council who can help guide
the reconstruction and will do a town by
town based on a criteria as to whether
there's a representative balanced local
local council there and and try to build
a new generation of leadership bottom-up
and use the reconstruction assistance
from the international community more
broadly as a lever to to promote gradual
and change within within a system that's
going to be dominated by Assad for the
foreseeable future
yeah is that in effect what we did in
Iraq before we pulled out I mean there
was there were actual democratic
elections there there was some local
control that was good we saw some some
seeds of liberalism popping up and then
and then we left and and it's probably
worse certainly worse now than it was at
that point is that in effect what we did
there well I mean it we it was a little
different in the sense that we that in
his second term
or surged American troops into Iraq
crushed the the insurgency which was an
al-qaeda-linked is urgency worked with
the the regime to crush a similar SIA
insurgency that was supported by Iran
and so both of those insurgencies were
crushed you did have some equilibrium
between the Kurdish the Shia and the
Sunni polities within that society that
had achieved a certain equilibrium a
significant American continued role was
probably necessary to counterbalance
Iranian influence to continue to
professionalize the Israel the Iraqi
security forces and to provide leverage
to sustain that delicate and difficult
balance among the groups and our
decision to leave withdrew that element
of stability and the situation
deteriorated so yes but I mean it was
different in the sense that that that we
had put you know he had gone all in and
with a hundred and seventy thousand
troops in a major campaign to suppress
the both of the extremists the Shia and
Sunni extremists in the country and
established us right in equilibrium in
Syria it's a little different I mean
we've supported these the insurgents
against the regime but we didn't support
them enough we were giving them just
enough aid to continue the war but not
enough to win it it's interesting
because it sort of harkens back to what
you started with about the continuity
between administrations because if I
remember correctly so when Obama was
running against Hillary as the
Democratic nominees back then 2007 that
one of the things that he was really
hitting her on was she was saying we're
gonna have to stay in Iraq a little bit
longer and he basically was saying we're
getting out we're getting out we're
getting out which in effect is what he
did even though it was signed by george
w bush that we were leaving before but
obviously we could have done whatever we
wanted but in effect what you're saying
is had we stayed a little bit longer
perhaps some of those institutions would
have been strengthened right so it was
sort of it's it's sort of no-win in a
way because if you don't want to be
there forever there's a problem and if
you leave too soon after
gone in and done as much as george w
bush did that then you're still kind of
yeah i mean in a bad spot
yes i mean i don't there's no simple
solutions i mean clearly it was a
mistake to have been graded iraq in the
first place but it was also a mistake to
leave once we'd done it they were in the
same situation in afghanistan and i
think on balance trumps probably made
the right decision there i mean that his
choices in afghanistan were easy to lose
or not lose it wasn't a third choice to
win i mean that's not an option
so the choices either leave and watch
the place returned to the taliban and
become a haven for al Qaeda Islamic
state other forms of extremism or
continue to support the government
establish some equilibrium in the state
which doesn't defeat the Taliban but
which prevents them from gaining further
ground so each of these situations
requires machlin that you can simply
apply Massiah them requires a specific
solution sometimes the solution is to
leave sometimes the solution is to stay
sometimes the solution is to is to is to
commit more to intensify the commitment
by that estimation do are we going to be
in Afghanistan forever I mean if there's
no win here and it's either stay and
play ball and it's not great and we're
spending a lot of resources or leave and
watch it go to hell how could we ever
get out it's the longest war in American
history I think at this point well and
that's a little misleading because the
first few years there really wasn't much
in the way of violence and we weren't it
was more so the roar didn't really
intensify until about 2006 but but see
but even then it's a long war but I mean
the point is I can't remember the
statistics but I mean we're losing I
think we this year we've lost like eight
people okay we probably lose more
soldiers and traffic accidents in the
United States
you know in all likelihood I don't know
those statistics we lost more people in
Lausanne in Las Vegas then than we've
lost in Vietnam analyst I'm sorry we
lost in Afghanistan last several years
so so you know we've been in Germany
forever we've been in North in South
Korea forever yeah we still have troops
in Kosovo nobody's complaining about
that you know we launched an operation
in Kosovo now it's 18 years ago and
still there we only have a few hundred
nobody's shooting at them so nobody
cares yeah so the answer is how long can
you stay in Afghanistan at current
levels engaged in the kinds of
activities we're engaged in I think we
can stay a long time it's not high on
the American political agenda nobody's
arguing we should leave nobody of
consequence the Trump's statement was
mildly criticized by some but but it
didn't there's no demonstrations in the
streets what would you say to those
people though for the few that there may
be in the public sphere that would just
say we need to get out of all of these
places why do we have soldiers and I
think there's something how many it's
something like twenty or thirty thousand
soldiers in Germany you know many many
years after World War two or that we
have these soldiers in South Korea from
putting Afghanistan aside here what
would you say to those people that well
why do we have any of these people here
don't these countries have armies and
borders and what do they need us for you
know I mean despite the appearance of
disarray in the level of conflict that
we see in the evening news we've lived
through the most peaceful and prosperous
period in human history there hasn't
been an award between a major state
since since really since the Korean War
so 1954 has it been a single war between
two major states there been lots of
small civil wars they reach their peak
actually in at the end of the Cold War
90s so at that point you had about 40
civil wars going on and and they
throughout the 90s most of those were
extinguished we're now at a period of
growth again so we're seeing more of
these small civil wars going on Syria
being an example but still I mean in
terms of the way most humanity lives
this has been the most peaceful and the
most prosperous era in human history
something like you know more than a
billion people were lifted out of
poverty over the last decade and decade
and a half and and so the the the the
fact that you had an American superpower
that was prepared to underwrite an
international system that was based on
certain norms the biggest norm being you
don't invade your neighbor that that
conquest is not a legitimate basis for
changing your borders and then a whole
bunch of subsidiary norms and
institutions like the World Bank like
the International Monetary Fund like the
the World Trade Organization and and the
United Nations all of these have created
a structure that has has an eliminated
conflict but it's definitely
circumscribed it kept it away from our
shores and and and would you want to go
back to us at the to a situation like
the 19th century the 18th century or
even the first half of the 20th century
which was the bloodiest period in human
history and would you want to go back to
a world like that with an increasing
number of countries that have nuclear
weapons well how do you how do you stop
them from having nuclear weapons well
the way we stopped our allies from
having nuclear weapons is to protect
them right and so why do we have troops
in Germany so that Germany doesn't
become a nuclear-armed superpower again
why do we have troops in Japan so Japan
doesn't become a nuclear-armed
superpower again same for South Korea do
you want to replicate the kind of
situation we had in the nineteen in the
1930s again in a world in which a
miscalculation could essentially end
humanity as we know it yeah
so you briefly mentioned the UN there
what do you make of what's happening
with the UN right now it seems the Trump
really has turned this thing on its head
nikki Haley is going in there and saying
we're not going to do things as they've
been done she's changing the way we're
going to vote on the Security Council
that is that sort of thing do you do you
sense that I think that this is a
rhetoric I mean the UN is an instrument
if if you can get agree if people agree
then it's a useful instrument if they
can't agree then it's timing I mean that
was designed that way it's not the UN's
fault if the Russians won't agree in
glocca Security Council you don't have a
Security Council mandate if you don't
have a Security Council mandate whatever
you do is going to be more controversial
it's going to get less support this is
just the way the system works but but I
think Haley has actually been rather
successful in in in moderating and
explaining American policy in terms that
are more broadly acceptable American
administrations because we pay with the
richest country in the world so we pay
the highest amount of the UN's dues I
think we pay like 22 percent mm-hmm
and so we're always arguing that it
should be more efficient and spend less
money that's not new to this
administration every administration
takes that takes that view so I don't I
don't see the Trump administration at
this point being particularly disruptive
in terms of the UN as an institution
well a couple times you've mentioned the
Kurds I think the the plight of the
Kurds is one of the most sort of
underreported stories they just had a
vote this week as we're taping this just
a few days ago on statehood I think it
was something like 95 percent said yes
but people don't seem to understand that
they're sort of caught in between Turkey
and Iraq and Syria and that they're an
ethnic Mont mine already trying to
figure out what their actual land and
country can be what what is our policy
related to the Kurds it's hard to tell
well I mean they're the Kurds are
distributed pretty evenly between
Turkey Iran Iraq and Syria there were
minority in all of those countries
they'd of course like to unite and
create a
their own but that means carving up for
other countries right and there's not
much enthusiasm about that so I think
that what the Kurds in Iraq had achieved
which is a high degree of autonomy they
had their own army mm-hmm they had
considerable control over their own
resources it was about the best that
they could expect and anything more
radical was going to be opposed by these
other countries largely because of the
precedent was set for their own Kurds I
think we've learned again and again the
breakup of Yugoslavia being the first
post-war example that the breaking up is
hard to do that it's costly that it
involves populated the unwilling
population transfers ethnic cleansing
even genocide the populations are
intermixed to the degree that there's no
clear separations and finding a way to
live together is almost always a better
solution and and and and one that's less
likely to generate conflict death
migration and and the pressures that
brings on the international system so I
mean our position is clear on on
northern Iraq which that is to say
Kurdish Iraq which is we don't want an
independent Kurdistan the Iraqi
Constitution creates a framework for
them to bargain with the government
including even bargaining potentially a
peaceful breakup of the country as
Czechoslovakia broke into Czech Republic
and Slovakia without any violence but
they have to pursue that path and that
and that a violent breakup a breakup
against the Constitution that we helped
write is is going to lead to just
further chaos in the region do we have a
policy related to the to the rest of the
Kurds so I understand we're saying the
KRG in Iraq in the Syrian the Syrian
Kurds are Maoist communists which nobody
reports on because they're fighting
the Islamic state yeah they're all hello
they're also associated with the PKK
which is the terrorist movement in of
Kurds in Turkey that are fighting the
Turkish government but they've been
reliable and very capable allies in the
fight against the Islamic state and so
we owe them a debt and and and and I
think have a need to continue to support
a modest expression of their aspirations
which is to create an autonomous zone
something like what exists in in Turkey
I'm sorry in Iraq where they can
continue to govern themselves within a
Syrian Federation but with a great deal
of local autonomy I think that's the
best they can get if they push it beyond
that they all have you know unite Syria
Iraq and Turkey against them and we're
not going to be able to protect them
yeah is that the inherent problem of
this that telling them well this is all
you can have all you can have is this
semi-autonomous place in Iraq even
though there's plenty of you in Turkey
and Syria and Iran that while I can
understand it from a diplomatic position
why that makes sense that that just
simply may not be enough for those
people it may not I mean I we face this
it when Yugoslavia broke up beginning
and in just that in in the late 90s and
or actually in the early 90s under
George HW Bush and and the dilemma was
that if it broke up it was going to be
violent
and yet it was going to break up so your
your policy choices were to acknowledge
the inevitable and acquiesce in it and
share responsibility for the resultant
carnage or oppose it avoid
responsibility you still have the
resulting carnage but rest you are
responsible for it you don't encourage
it you didn't endorse it right so
millions of people were going to be
dispossessed hundreds of thousands were
going to be
kill did you want to endorse that or did
you want to oppose it mm-hmm and the
answer is we normally want to oppose it
now the question is can you oppose it
effectively enough to prevent it right
that's hard that's expensive but
opposing it enough to just say not our
fault you know that's easy and and the
alternative would be to say let's work
with it it's gonna happen let's try to
make it happen as as as peacefully asked
as we can and the problem there is that
is is that you're probably not going to
be able to be influential enough to
succeed and you're gonna buy the result
you're gonna be hard with the result and
so that's the policymakers dilemma right
or yeah I guess you're selling the
result to the person that's gonna come
after you and either way something
something bad is gonna happen let's talk
about two other places that we've hit on
a little bit here so Iran right now I'm
seeing a whole bunch of chatter on on
Twitter I'm probably spending too much
time on Twitter but chatter on Twitter
about that the Iran deal is actually not
working that they're not doing what they
have to do we don't have a way of
verifying all of this what's your basic
thoughts on the deal in the first place
and then sort of where we're at well I
mean a deal as written is certainly
working it's working exactly as it was
written
Obama certified that every 90 days and
opened Trump is certified it twice
written certified it's working it's
doing they're doing everything they're
required to do meaning we have verified
everything in the signed document but
that's that were that we're completely
satisfied that they're doing everything
they're supposed to do and so Trump has
twice certified that to be true to
Congress so the complaint that you know
and and there's intrusive verification
by the IAEA inspectors and and the US
intelligence community is completely
unified and saying yes they're doing
what they promised to do mm-hmm
there's really no factual dispute there
despite whatever you may be reading on
the Internet that's why I'm asking you
yeah so so you know that there is there
are two levels of complaint
that have some basis one is the
agreement doesn't go far enough so it
doesn't cover their missile program it
doesn't stop them from providing
missiles to Hezbollah that can strike
Israel it doesn't strike to stop them
from supporting Assad it doesn't strike
stop them from supporting the Hootie's
cm and already in Yemen it doesn't stop
them from supporting SIA in Bahrain it
doesn't stop them from making the Saudis
miserable so basically that's just the
criticism of the deal that was so so you
know and the answer was it wasn't
intended to do that and and it also
didn't the the agreement doesn't require
us to lift all our sanctions it only it
required us to lift the sanctions we put
on connected with their nuclear program
and all the sanctions we put on because
there's a human rights record and their
attacks on Israel and their behavior
elsewhere those sanctions all continue
to exist and we can continue to add to
the mm-hmm
okay so that's that level of complaint
do you see that as a legitimate
complaint that that somehow that all
should have been tied together you know
I mean I think you know separate what
you can I don't think just to solve all
those other things we would have had to
make much broader concessions ourselves
those who aren't prepared to make okay
the second complaint is that some of the
the aspects of the agreement run out its
some of them some goes for 10 years some
15 there's a they may have ingest said
they're not going to make nuclear
weapons they've halted a wide range of
nuclear activities and shipped out
highly enriched uranium stopped
enriching uranium to a certain level it
closed down certain reactors in other
words there's a lot of things and these
things are time faced the they all last
at least 10 years some of them are lasts
a bit longer and some of them and some
of them terminate but so to our site our
promise not to apply sanctions
terminates - so yes at some point in the
next 10 years we should sit down and
either extend the existing agreement or
a better yet
supplemented with an even wider
agreement that covers other issues but
that's not that that's that's a problem
we've got a decade to solve and just
walking away from the agreement I mean
that there's walking away remember
there's two alternates what are the
alternatives one is they resume their
nuclear program and have nuclear weapons
within a year mm-hmm alternative two is
we go to war to stop them a war with
Iran doesn't end in a month or a year it
we'd have to do what we did with Iraq
from the end of the first Gulf War until
the invasion of Iraq which is overfly
them every day bomb them every time we
see them doing something suspicious and
essentially it's a permanent conflict
but it's much more difficult because
with Iraq we had a Security Council
resolution that authorized us to overfly
them every day right on them whenever we
saw our suspicious activity
people forget that that we actually did
go to the UN for that right and and and
we had bases in neighboring countries
like Turkey the British and the French
also overflew Iraq every day and bombed
them when they did something suspicious
and the world was perfectly content with
that and endorsed it but if we walk away
from this agreement we're not going to
have a Security Council resolution to
authorize us to go to war we're not
gonna have any allies in that war we're
gonna be the one that's isolated and so
which do you want a war with Iran or
Iran with nuclear weapons those are your
alternatives or keep the keep the
existing agreement and negotiate a
follow-on with more provisions right so
that it's an interesting way of looking
at it that basically this bought us it
didn't do everything all those issues
that you mentioned but it also bought us
some time here to hopefully deal with
some of that while at the same time when
when this thing sets ten years from now
or whatever it is now eight years from
now that we can then renegotiate and
hopefully we'll be in a better position
for whatever reason or the regime won't
be as strong or a series of other things
that we just right won't know so it's a
diplomatic lien on that one yeah I mean
it was you know you bought ten years and
you know problems you know the problems
that our crises that are postponed often
too
go away so you know we postponed a
crisis but with the Soviet Union for 40
years and it went away right right so we
shall see on this one yeah let's shift
to North Korea a little bit we just did
a show on North Korea with Michael
malleus who's an author and a journalist
who spent some time there but I do sense
that people really don't know too much
about North Korea or understand the the
actors and everything that's going on
here what's the sort of simplest way you
can describe the regime and and how they
behave well it's a very personalized
regime it's a family regime you're now
in the third generation of leaders it's
it's isolated it's it's highly
authoritarian its brutal it has no
democratic legitimacy or and it and it
makes no effort to achieve it it governs
by intimidation and propaganda and it's
a national security state it sees itself
as beleaguered it is beleaguered largely
as a result of its own behavior meleave
z-- that South Korea wants it to go away
wants to reunify Korea which of course
it does
so does North Korea want to unify Korea
it believes that the United States is is
hostile and bent on regime change which
in a sense we are I mean any we want to
change all of our Aryan regimes in a
very generalized way but we're not
actively you know mounting a campaign to
overthrow the regime in Pyongyang if we
thought we could we might be tempted but
I don't think we we see any real
prospect there
it's a regime that that was almost on
its last legs a few years ago
large-scale starvation mismanaged
economy it's under the new leadership of
Kim jong-un the economy has picked up
and fear that the situation that the
regime is just going to implode which
was the the principal concern of North
Korea of five or ten years ago was it
was just going to implode and then what
what we're going to do now
I think that's less likely and the
concern is growing nuclear capabilities
and not so much that they will use them
although that's a danger but that they
will employ them to intimidate and
threaten their neighbors and to and and
to defend to protect even more
outrageous behavior we could probably do
another hour on that right there but
we've actually done it now already but I
thought we could end this this one by
really quick and I can talk about
foreign policy all day and I love
hearing some of the insights that we
just can't get from the average people
that are talking about this stuff all
the time
I don't you've an interesting anecdote
about tear down this wall the Reagan
speech I thought maybe we could end on
that yeah this is the book that I just
published called Foreign Service which
is account of my 50 years in diplomacy
and so I was the deputy chief of mission
the number two in our embassy in West
Germany which and the capital of West
Germany was bond not Berlin but but
Reagan was going to visit Berlin and so
I flew ahead a few days before his
intended trip to scout out locations for
what the White House intended to be a
major speech and so I went around to
several different locations and and the
one I liked best was a a location
directly in front of the Brandenburg
Gate which is associated with Berlin the
way the Empire State is would with you
know with New York you do have any idea
of while you were searching out the spot
the level of which this speech was going
well I didn't I I knew it was gonna be a
major speech and a major speech by a
president you'd had of course the the
Kennedy speech in Berlin in which he
said ich bin ein Berliner I'm you know
I'm a Berlin
which was you know a major event and and
still reverberates even today so I knew
that this was it was going to be a
symbolic and important occasion so the
the the the the location I thought was
best sickness telegenic ly if you will
was in front of the brandenburg gate
through which Hitler's armies at march
the kaisers armies march which was now
walled off and sealed at the city and
the people in our mission and Berlin in
East in Berlin and West Berlin said you
know this will be controversial both the
East Germans and maybe the West Germans
will regard this as as as a provocation
so maybe we should go to a little more
neutral location but dry persistent went
back and talked to the White House
advance team and sold them on the
location I didn't know that he was going
to say mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
and in fact there's an anecdote in which
he's driving to the event and someone on
the White House staff tells him that he
ought to drop that line yeah and he he
says no I think it'll be okay
and so that's probably you know the
single most important singles
presidential speech that has still
reverberates most yeah well it's been a
pleasure talking to you I love talking
about foreign policy there's so much
more we could do will you come back and
do this again sometime up - all right we
will do this again sometime and you're
not huge on Twitter which i think is the
key to your whole operation but you are
but you are on twitter jim underscore
Dobbins and we're gonna link to a few of
his works down below
you
[Music]